can we talk about the real masterpiece
airing the season though oh and joey
joey knows what i'm talking about it was
really funny because i was
i was just about to bring it up
so so forget forget this attack on titan
slando or like whatever we're going to
call the classic
yeah the real classic that's coming out
this season is an anime called
x-arm so i'm a i'm a complete noob now i
have seen clips of it but can you please
explain to me what exam is in its
total it is hilarious it is
an experience i will say that so
i think we have literally got the mass
effect andromeda releases of anime
if you know what i mean cyberpunk finish
yeah
so this is i didn't know anime could
have bugs and glitches that's all i'm
gonna say
so it is a crunchyroll original
right and you know that crunchyroll are
proud of this because i have not seen
a single piece of promotional work about
this
i saw the trailer on youtube and i
thought it was a
joke and the show looks
worse than that no it looks it looks
worse yeah i
i hate to say to you but the trailer is
probably the best part about the show
yeah the trailer isn't a trailer the
trailer is the anime
probably makes it good doesn't it but
it's so bad
oh dude i was crying in laughter the
first episode it
is like i think the third lowest anime
on mal
right now after one episode after one
episode but you're laughing so
yeah i mean it's it's uh that's that's
what it's a masterpiece
of trash basically it's it's no
masterpiece
it is a mark it's like it's like the
first time i watched like ghazi's wing
right
yeah or like in a helter skev and i was
like a skill to heaven i was like this
is
i'm watching a masterpiece but on the
opposite end so so to explain next time
it is a control original
anime um that is made by a completely
new studio
by a team who's never worked in anime
before american
no japanese japanese team but uh they've
never worked in anime before and
it shows okay it shows it shows that
they've never worked an anime before and
um it is a 3d anime that looks
like it was made by a five-year-old who
just learned blender
like yesterday um it makes
ruby look like it makes ruby season one
look like an absolute master i was gonna
watch it but i just wanted to get like
drunk enough yeah just to like fully
enjoy it oh it makes berserk 2016 look
like akira you know what i mean yeah
it's pretty bad it is and what's worse
is that like i posted the clip of it on
twitter but like there's a scene right
near the beginning
where the main character is 3d but his
brother
is in 2d so you have this
truly awful [ __ ] cg like blocky
minecraft character
standing next to this 2d anime character
and he literally in the same scene
in the same shot and he literally looks
he literally looks green screened on
you know what i mean it looks like
someone just learned it looked like
someone just had learned this
the he's like he's like two spots like
you heard of this thing called a chroma
key
exactly
you can see it on screen right now oh my
god
oh my god that's awful it's like in the
same
scene you know what that is that's like
that looks like if you told me that was
uh what's that uh what's that game where
everyone can have their own avatars in
the game it looks like they're like
second life whatever it's called yeah it
looks like it's like you know how like
someone
people have their own servers name like
2d things and they have like the 3d
models
that's what it looks like you know what
that looks like that looks like someone
took like a regular anime and made like
an mmd edit of it
see it i can see it because it is like
that quality actually mmd's are better
in the
mmd it's a pretty damn good mmd yeah
yeah
don't be hating on my mmd and then like
if if
that wasn't already bad there was just
like some of the fight choreography
is just hilarious like this is one fight
scene i think like
it's like the last fight scene of the
first episode where there was just no
music
it's like they forgot to put in the
music it's just like
like that but there's no music
whatsoever so it's just i was watching
it and i was just like is
something wrong with my headphones like
why is there no music playing
i remember like in the last part they
run out or something and it's literally
a guy who looks like
literally it's literally looks like the
characters are like being animated with
a stick or something like that
there's literally no like they're not
moving their limbs or something they're
just like
rocking from side to side so we're
talking that like
that like queen bee would put them to
shame oh i wish this was animated by
queen
oh dude it makes queen bee look like
studio weird
it's it's [ __ ] horrible yeah but it's
also just a really fun time like i had a
lot of fun watching the first episode
yeah
always see what i mean i want to get
some drinks and just enjoy it you know
oh we need to it's so funny
this would be like even better if it had
like kind of like a ghost stories dub
so someone needs to dub exxon
crunchyroll
please don't be ashamed of exxon you're
sitting on a golden duck here
just just market it correctly and people
will meme the [ __ ] out give us the
rights to dublin
we'll [ __ ] dub it we'll [ __ ] make
an amazing double bit you know what i
mean
can't wait to direct those sessions
and like the opening song as well
just what is that the one that sounds
like some some 41.
yeah it sounds like yeah it sounds like
it sounds like a sun 41 cover
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i heard that
was the one they used for the trailer
right yeah yeah yeah yeah that that is
just the anime
yeah just sent me it was like what the
[ __ ] is this it's like some 2002 [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] what is this
god damn it's it's like it's like a high
school band that listened to too much
green day you know what i mean
it does sound like a cover band isn't it
oh my god that is perfect but yeah why
is no one talking about that
i don't know about you you have attack
on titan season four but who gives a
[ __ ] about it
who greenlit that like no sorry like who
who let that through like
quality assurance like who led that
through what quality [ __ ]
like there's normally people who are
like yeah this is good to go who
who deadass watched that first episode
was like yeah it's good
i wonder though if someone at like the
production team was like
i feel like we're forgetting something
qa oh [ __ ]
you know how sometimes when like people
like make shows but it's just one big
like
tax fraud scheme yeah what if it's like
i shouldn't say that i could get in
trouble actually
it's definitely always just a joke
that's a joke that's a joke
you know just saying oh my god but like
i wonder what the people working on it
think of this you know anime because you
know so
sometimes sometimes you work on a
project that you're
not proud of us you know you know what i
mean because
people want to get paid god yeah right
like at the end of the day
they're like i mean i gotta just keep
turning up and doing what they ask right
that's what i imagine is happening i
don't know
i just like to imagine that like the
animes came back to like the producer
and was like
yeah the the models look great um so
like put some shading on it put you know
a little more animation on the producers
like so it's coming out tomorrow
i just i just want to know because you
know and like in any like anime
production or any big project production
you know you have this
you have this screening night right
where you you as a group
as the team you get to watch the final
product before it airs
i just want to hear the silence in that
room when the credits roll
and you just you just what can you say
here's the thing psych in japan it's
always silent
that's why see in america this is yeah
and the west we have clapping right
i just like to think that the entire
like screening room is just like
silently nodding their head
hell yeah everyone knows every japanese
man's just waiting for the izakaya
anyway yeah
come on i just want a beer man they're
gonna get a free meal at the end of the
screening and free drinks so it doesn't
matter like that they're turning up to
the screen i turn up to the screening if
i get free meal at the end of it
listen man like as someone who's like
you know done a documentary in an anime
studio i
i completely simply wow look at that
flesh
is somewhat catty i get it
it's hard but also
come on
it's hard but come on man it's hard you
know we're not we're not blaming the
probably
overworked staff not at all i'm not
blaming anyone for it if anything i'd
like to thank them for giving us some
like quality entertainment honestly it
is
honestly quality entertainment i i watch
episode two and it is
also a banger oh i still need to just
coming out with that
episode man exam episode 2 is what i'm
looking forward to